welcome to another episode of don't get
forked my name is Ryan I'm the club
manager here and this show is about
showing puzzles that all involve Forks
we have contestants come up a lot of
employees and club members will come up
they'll look at a puzzle and try to
figure out how the best way to not get
forked and just so there's no confusion
about what a fork is a fork is one one
piece attacks two other pieces any piece
can fork so all of our puzzles are
supplied by international Messer Eric
Rosen so thank you very much for that
and let's go to the board welcome back
to round three of don't get forked with
us today is our National Arbor Mike
comer all right Mike you know the rules
correct correct on the board there's
gonna be White's turn to move and make
the best one with a forward on the board
to not get for it are you ready in three
seconds you can turn around face the
board you'll have 30 seconds are you
ready
got yup three two one go what's going
what's going on what's going to move
where's the something happening my
knight on a three second wants to check
me you want to check in so bad I want to
go all the way back do I want to go all
the way back that is the correct comer
you get a fork thank you so much about
the view of us all right thank you
[Laughter]
alright thanks for joining us on don't
get forked please like share and
subscribe to all our videos and if you
have any good fork puzzles please send
them to info at st. Louis chess club org
thanks